[Music]
a friend of mine
who is a man of letters and a
philosopher said to me one day
as if between jess and ernest fancy
since we last met i have discovered a
haunted house in the midst of london
really haunted and by what ghosts
well i can't answer that question all i
know is this
six weeks ago my wife and i were in
search of a furnished apartment
passing a quiet street we saw in the
window of one of the houses a bill
apartments furnished the situation
suited us
we entered the house liked the rooms
engaged them by the week
and left them the third day no power on
earth could have reconciled my wife to
stay longer
and i don't wonder at it what did you
see
excuse me i have no desire to be
ridiculed as a superstitious dreamer
nor on the other hand could i ask you to
accept on my affirmation
what you would hold to be incredible
without the evidence of your own senses
let me only say this it was not so much
what we saw
or heard in which you might fairly
suppose that we were the dupes of our
own excited fancy
or the victims of imposter and others
that drove us away
as it was an undefinable terror which
seized both of us whenever we passed by
the door of a certain unfurnished room
in which we neither saw nor heard
anything and the strangest marvel of all
was
that for once in my life i agreed with
my wife
silly woman though she be and allowed
after the third night
that it was impossible to stay a fourth
in that house
accordingly on the fourth morning i
summoned the woman who kept the house
and attended on us
and told her that the rooms did not
quite suit us and we would not stay out
our week
she said dryly i know why you have
stayed longer than any other lodger
few ever stayed a second night none
before you a third
but i take it they have been very kind
to you
they who i asked affecting to smile
why they who haunt the house whoever
they are
i don't mind them i remember them many
years ago
when i lived in this house not as a
servant
but i know they will be the death of me
someday
i don't care i'm old and must die soon
anyhow
and then i shall be with them and in
this house still
the woman spoke with so dreary a
calmness that really it was a sort of
awe that prevented my conversing with
her further
i paid for my weak and too happy were my
wife and i to get off so cheaply
you excite my curiosity said i nothing i
should like better than to sleep in a
haunted house
pray give me the address of the one
which you left so ignominiously
my friend gave me the address and when
we parted i walked straight towards the
house thus indicated
it is situated on the north side of
oxford street in a dull but respectable
thoroughfare
i found the house shut up no bill at the
window
and no response to my knock as i was
turning away
a beer boy collecting pewter pots at the
neighboring areas
said to me do you want anyone at that
house sir
yes i heard it was to be let let
why the woman who kept it is dead has
been dead these three weeks
and no one can be found to stay there
though mr j offered ever so much
he offered mother who charged for him a
pound a week
just to open and shut the windows and
she would not would not
and why the house is haunted
and the old woman who kept it was found
dead in her bed with her eyes wide open
they say the devil strangled her poo
you speak of mr j is he the owner of the
house
yes where does he live
in gower street number 33 what is he
in any business no sir nothing
particular
a single gentleman i gave the pop boy
the gratuity earned by his liberal
information
and proceeded to mr jay in gower street
which was close by the street that
boasted the haunted house
i was lucky enough to find mr j at home
an elderly man
with intelligent countenance and
pre-possessing manners
i communicated my name and my business
frankly
i said i had heard the house was
considered to be haunted that i had a
strong desire to examine a house with so
equivocal a reputation
that i should be greatly obliged if he
would allow me to hire it
though only for a night i was willing to
pay for that privilege whatever he might
be inclined to ask
sir said mr j with great courtesy
the house is at your service for as
short or as long a time as you please
rent is out of the question the
obligation will be on my side
should you be able to discover the cause
of the strange phenomena
which at present deprive it of all value
i cannot let it
for i cannot even get a servant to keep
it in order or to answer the door
unluckily the house is haunted if i may
use that expression
not only by night but by day though at
night the disturbances are of a more
unpleasant
and sometimes of a more alarming
character the poor old woman who died in
it three weeks ago
was a pauper whom i took out of a
workhouse for in her childhood
she had been known to some of my family
and had once been in such good
circumstances that she had rented that
house of my uncle
she was a woman of superior education
and strong mind
and was the only person i could ever
induce to remain in the house
indeed since her death which was sudden
and the coroner's inquest
which gave it a notoriety in the
neighborhood i have so despaired of
finding any person to take charge of the
house
much more a tenant that i would
willingly let it rent free for a year
to anyone who would pay its rates and
taxes
how long is it since the house acquired
this sinister character
that i can scarcely tell you but very
many years since
the old woman i spoke of said it was
haunted when she rented it between 30
and 40 years ago
the fact is that my life has been spent
in the east indies
and in the civil service of the company
i returned to england last year
on inheriting the fortune of an uncle
among whose possessions was the house in
question
i found it shut up and uninhabited i was
told that it was haunted
that no one would inhabit it i smiled at
what seemed to me so idle a story
i spent some money in repairing it added
to its old-fashioned furniture a few
modern articles
advertised it and obtained a lodger for
a year
he was a colonel on half pay he came in
with his family
a son and a daughter and four or five
servants
they all left the house the next day and
although each of them declared that he
had seen something different
from that which had scared the others as
something still was equally terrible to
all
i really could not in conscience sue nor
even blame the colonel
for breach of agreement then i put in
the old woman i have spoken of
and she was empowered to let the house
in apartments
i never had one lodger who stayed more
than three days
i do not tell you their stories to know
two lodgers have there been exactly the
same phenomena repeated
it is better that you should judge for
yourself than enter the house with an
imagination
influenced by previous narratives only
be prepared to see and to hear something
or other
and take whatever precautions you
yourself please
have you never had a curiosity yourself
to pass a night in that house
yes i passed not a night but three hours
in broad daylight
alone in that house my curiosity is not
satisfied but it is quenched
i have no desire to renew the experiment
you cannot complain you see sir that i
am not sufficiently candid
and unless your interest be exceedingly
eager and your nerves unusually strong
i honestly add that i advise you not to
pass a knight in that house
my interest is exceedingly keen said i
and though only a coward will boast of
his nerves in situations wholly
unfamiliar
to him yet my nerves have been seasoned
in such variety of danger
that i have the right to rely on them
even in a haunted house
mr j said very little more he took the
keys of the house out of his bureau
gave them to me and thanking him
cordially for his frankness
and his urbane concession to my wish i
carried off my prize
impatient for the experiment as soon as
i reached home
i summoned my confidential servant a
young man of gay spirits
fearless temper and is free from
superstitious prejudice as anyone i
could think of
frank said i you remember in germany how
disappointed we were at not finding a
ghost in that old
castle which was said to be haunted by a
headless apparition
well i've heard of a house in london
which i have reason to hope
is decidedly haunted i mean to sleep
there tonight
from what i hear there is no doubt that
something will allow itself to be seen
or to be heard
something perhaps excessively horrible
do you think if i take you with me i may
rely on your presence of mind whatever
may happen
oh sir pray trust me answered frank
grinning with delight
very well then here are the keys of the
house this is the address
go now select for me any bedroom you
please
and since the house has not been
inhabited for weeks make up a good fire
air the bed well see of course that
there are candles as well as fuel
take with you my revolver and my dagger
so much for my weapons
arm yourself equally well and if we are
not a match for a dozen ghosts
we shall be but a sorry couple of
englishmen
i was engaged for the rest of the day on
business so urgent
that i had not leisure to think much on
the nocturnal adventure to which i had
plighted my honor i dined alone
and very late and while dining read as
is my habit
i selected one of the volumes of
mccauley's essays
i thought to myself that i would take
the book with me there was so much of
healthfulness and the style
and practical life in the subjects that
it would serve as an antidote against
the influences of superstitious fancy
accordingly about half past nine i put
the book into my pocket
and strolled leisurely towards the
haunted house
i took with me a favorite dog an
exceedingly sharp
bold and vigilant bull terrier a dog
fond of prowling about
strange ghostly corners and passages at
night in search of rats
a dog of dogs for a ghost it was a
summer night but chilly
the sky somewhat gloomy and overcast
still there was a moon faint and sickly
but still a moon
and if the clouds permitted after
midnight it would be brighter
i reached the house knocked and my
servant opened with a cheerful smile
all right sir and very comfortable
oh said i rather disappointed have you
not seen
or heard anything remarkable well sir i
must own i have heard something queer
what what the sound of feet patterning
behind me
and once or twice small noises like
whispers close at my ear
nothing more you are not at all
frightened
i not a bit of it sir and the man's bold
look reassured me on one point
namely that happened what might he would
not desert me
we were in the hall the street door
closed and my attention was now drawn to
my dog
he had at first run in eagerly enough
but had sneaked back to the door
and was scratching and whining to get
out
after patting him on the head and
encouraging him gently
the dog seemed to reconcile himself to
the situation
and followed me and frank through the
house but keeping close at my heels
instead of hurrying inquisitively in
advance
which was his usual and normal habit in
all strange places
we first visited the subterranean
apartments the kitchen
and other offices and especially the
cellars in which last there were two or
three bottles of wine still left in a
bin
covered with cobwebs and evidently by
their appearance
undisturbed for many years it was clear
that the ghosts were not wine bibbers
for the rest we discovered nothing of
interest there was a gloomy little
backyard with very high walls
the stones of this yard were very damp
and what with the damp and what with the
dust and smoke grime on the pavement
our feet left a slight impression where
we passed
and now appeared the first strange
phenomenon witnessed by myself in this
strange abode
i saw just before me the print if a foot
suddenly form itself
as it were i stopped caught hold of my
servant
and pointed to it in advance of that
footprint
has suddenly dropped another we both saw
it
i advanced quickly to the place the
footprint kept advancing before me
a small footprint the foot of a child
the impression was too faint thoroughly
to distinguish the shape
but it seemed to us both that it was the
print of a naked foot
this phenomenon ceased when we arrived
at the opposite wall
nor did it repeat itself on returning we
rebounded the stairs and entered the
rooms on the ground floor
a dining parlor a small back parlor and
a still smaller third room that had been
probably appropriated to a footman
all still as death we then visited the
drawing rooms
which seemed fresh and new in the front
room i seated myself in an armchair
frank placed on the table the
candlestick with which he had lighted us
i told him to shut the door as he turned
to do so a chair opposite to me moved
from the wall
quickly and noiselessly and dropped
itself about a yard from my own chair
immediately fronting it why this is
better than the turning tables
said i with a half laugh and as i
laughed my dog put back his head and
howled
frank coming back had not observed the
movement of the chair
he employed himself now instilling the
dog
i continued to gaze on the chair and
fancied i saw on it a pale blue misty
outline of a human figure
but an outline so indistinct that i
could only distrust my own vision
the dog now was quiet put back that
chair opposite
to me said i to frank put it back to the
wall
frank obeyed was that you sir said he
turning abruptly i what
why something struck me i felt it
sharply on the shoulder
just here no said i but we have jugglers
present
and though we may not discover their
tricks we shall catch them
before they frighten us we did not stay
long in the drawing rooms
in fact they felt so damp and so chilly
that i was glad to get to the fire
upstairs
we locked the doors of the drawing rooms
a precaution which i should observe
we had taken with all the rooms we had
searched below
the bedroom my servant had selected for
me was the best on the floor
a large one with two windows fronting
the street
the four-posted bed which took up no
inconsiderable space
was opposite to the fire which burned
clear and bright
a door in the wall to the left between
the bed and the window
communicated with the room which my
servant appropriated to himself
this last was a small room with a sofa
bed and had no communication with the
landing place
no other door but that which conducted
to the bedroom i was to occupy
on either side of my fireplace was a
cupboard without locks
flush with the wall and covered with the
same dull brown paper
we examined these cupboards only hooks
to suspend
female dresses nothing else we sounded
the walls
evidently solid the outer walls of the
building
[Music]
having finished the survey of these
apartments warmed myself a few moments
and lighted my cigar
i then still accompanied by frank went
forth to complete my reconnoiter
in the landing place there was another
door it was closed firmly
sir said my servant in surprise i
unlocked this door with all the others
when i first came
it cannot have got locked from the
inside for
before he had finished his sentence the
door which neither of us
then was touching opened quietly of
itself
we looked at each other a single instant
the same
thought seized both some human agency
might be detected here
i rushed in first my servant followed
a small blank dreary room without
furniture
a few empty boxes and hampers in a
corner a small window
the shutters closed not even a fireplace
no other door but that by which we had
entered no carpet on the floor
and the floor seemed very old uneven
worm eaten
mended here and there as was shown by
the whiter patches on the wood
but no living being and no visible place
in which a living being could have
hidden
as we stood gazing round the door by
which we had entered closed as quietly
as it had before opened we were
imprisoned
for the first time i felt a creep of
undefinable horror
not so my servant why they don't think
to trap us sir
i could break that trumpery door with a
kick of my foot
try first if it will open to your hand
said i shaking off the vague
apprehension that had seized me
while i unclose the shutters and see
what is without
i unbarred the shutters the window
looked on the little backyard i have
before described
there was no ledge without nothing to
break the sheer descent of the wall
no man getting out of that window would
have found any footing till he had
fallen on the stones below
frank meanwhile was vainly attempting to
open the door
he now turned round to me and asked my
permission to use force
and i should hear state injustice to the
servant
that far from evincing any superstitious
terrors
his nerve composure and even gayty amid
circumstances so extraordinary
compelled my admiration and made me
congratulate myself on having secured a
companion in every way fitted to the
occasion
i willingly gave him the permission he
required
but though he was a remarkably strong
man his force was as idle as his milder
efforts
the door did not even shake to his
stoutest kick breathless in panting he
desisted
i then tried the door myself equally in
vain
as i ceased from the effort again that
creep of horror came over me
but this time it was more cold and
stubborn
i felt as if some strange and ghastly
exhalation were rising up from the
chinks of that rugged floor
and filling the atmosphere with a
venomous influence hostile to human life
the door now very slowly and quietly
opened as of its own accord
we precipitated ourselves into the
landing place
we both saw a large pale light as large
as the human figure
but shapeless and unsubstantial move
before us
and ascend the stairs that led from the
landing into the attics
i followed the light and my servant
followed me
it entered to the right of the landing a
small garrett
of which the door stood open i entered
in the same instant
the light then collapsed into a small
globule exceedingly brilliant and vivid
rested a moment on a bed in the corner
quivered and vanished
we approached the bed and examined it a
half tester
such as is commonly found in addicts
devoted to servants
on the drawers that stood near it we
perceived an old faded silk kerchief
with the needle still left in a rent
half repaired
the kerchief was covered with dust
probably it had belonged to the old
woman who had last died in that house
and this might have been her sleeping
room i had sufficient curiosity to open
the drawers
there were a few odds and ends of female
dress and two letters
tied round with a narrow ribbon of faded
yellow
i took the liberty to possess myself of
the letters
we found nothing else in the room worth
noticing nor did the light reappear
but we distinctly heard as we turned to
go a patterning footfall on the floor
just before us we went through the other
attics
in all four the footfall still preceding
us
nothing to be seen nothing but the
footfall heard
i had the letters in my hand just as i
was descending the stairs i distinctly
felt my wrist seized
and a faint soft effort made to draw the
letters from my clasp
i only held them the more tightly and
the effort ceased
we regained the bedchamber appropriated
to myself
and i then remarked that my dog had not
followed us when we had left it
he was thrusting himself close to the
fire and trembling i was impatient to
examine the letters
and while i read them my servant opened
a little box in which he had deposited
the weapons i had ordered him to bring
took them out placed them on a table
close at my bed head
and then occupied himself in soothing
the dog who however
seemed to heed him very little the
letters were short
they were dated the dates exactly 35
years ago
they were evidently from a lover to his
mistress or a husband
to some young wife not only the terms of
expression but a distinct reference to a
former voyage
indicated the writer to have been a
seafarer
the spelling and handwriting were those
of a man imperfectly educated but still
the language itself was forcible
in the expressions of endearment there
was a kind of rough wild love
but here and there were dark
unintelligible hints at some secret not
of love
some secret that seemed of crime we
ought to love each other
was one of the sentences i remember for
how everyone else would execrate us
if all was known again don't let anyone
be in the same room with you at night
you talk in your sleep and again what's
done can't be
undone and i tell you there's nothing
against us unless the dead could come to
life
here there was underlined in a better
handwriting of females
they do at the end of the letter latest
in date the same female hand had written
these words
lost at sea the fourth of june the same
day as
i put down the letters and began to muse
over their contents
fearing however that the train of
thought into which i fell
might unsteady my nerves i fully
determined to keep my mind in a fit
state to cope with whatever of marvelous
the advancing night might bring forth
i roused myself laid the letters on the
table
stirred up the fire which was still
bright and cheering
and opened my volume of macaulay i read
quietly enough
till about half past eleven i then threw
myself dressed upon the bed
and told my servant he might retire to
his own room but must keep himself awake
i bade him leave open the door between
the two rooms
thus alone i kept two candles burning on
the table by my bed head
i placed my watch beside the weapons and
calmly resumed my macaulay
opposite to me the fire burned clear and
on the hearth rug
seemingly asleep lay the dog in about 20
minutes i felt an exceedingly cold air
pass by my cheek
like a sudden draft i fancied the door
to my right
communicating with the landing place
must have got open
but no it was closed i then turned my
glance to my left
and saw the flame of the candles
violently swayed as by a wind
at the same moment the watch beside the
revolver softly slid from the table
softly softly no visible hand
it was gone i sprang up seizing the
revolver with the one hand
the dagger with the other i was not
willing that my weapons should share the
fate of the watch
thus armed i looked round the floor no
sign of the watch
three slow loud distinct knocks were now
heard at the bed head
my servant called out is that you sir
no be on your guard the dog now roused
himself
and sat on his haunches his ears moving
quickly backwards and forwards
he kept his eyes fixed on me with a look
so strange that he concentrated all my
attention on himself
slowly he rose up all his hair bristling
and stood perfectly rigid
and with the same wild stare i had no
time however
to examine the dog presently my servant
emerged from his room
and if ever i saw horror in the human
face it was then
i should not have recognized him had we
met in the street
so altered was every lineament he passed
by me quickly
saying in a whisper that seemed scarcely
to come from his lips
run run it is after me he gained the
door to the landing
pulled it open and rushed forth i
followed him into the landing
involuntarily
calling him to stop but without heeding
me he bounded down the stairs
clinging to the balusters and taking
several steps at a time
i heard where i stood the street door
open heard it again clapped too
i was left alone in the haunted house
it was but for a moment that i remained
undecided whether or not to follow my
servant
pride and curiosity alike forbade so
dastardly of flight
i re-entered my room closing the door
after me
and proceeded cautiously into the
interior chamber
i encountered nothing to justify my
servant's terror
i again carefully examined the walls to
see if there were any concealed door
i could find no trace of one not even a
seam in the dull brown paper with which
the room was hung
how then had the thing whatever it was
which had so scared him
obtained ingress except through my own
chamber
i returned to my room shut and locked
the door that opened upon the interior
one
and stood on the hearth expectant and
prepared
i now perceived that the dog had slunk
into an angle of the wall
and was pressing himself close against
it as if literally striving to force his
way into it
i approached the animal and spoke to it
the poor brute was evidently beside
itself with terror
it showed all its teeth the slaver
dropping from its jaws
and would certainly have bitten me if i
had touched it it did not seem to
recognize me
whoever is seen at the zoological
gardens a rabbit
fascinated by a serpent cowering in a
corner may form some idea of the anguish
which the dog exhibited
finding all efforts to soothe the animal
in vain and fearing that his bite might
be as venomous in that state
as in the madness of hydrophobia i left
him alone
placed my weapons on the table beside
the fire seated myself
and re-commenced my macaulay perhaps in
order not to appear seeking credit for a
courage
or rather a coolness which the reader
may conceive i exaggerate
i may be pardoned if i pause to indulge
in one or two egotistical remarks
as i hold presence of mind or what is
called courage
to be precisely proportioned to
familiarity with the circumstances that
lead to it
so i should say that i had been long
sufficiently familiar with all
experiments that appertained to the
marvelous
i had witnessed many very extraordinary
phenomena in various parts of the world
phenomena that would either be totally
disbelieved if i stated them
or ascribed to supernatural agencies
now my theory is that the supernatural
is the impossible
and that what is called supernatural is
only a something in the laws of nature
of which we have been hitherto ignorant
therefore
if a ghost rise before me i have not the
right to say
so then the supernatural is possible but
rather
so then the apparition of a ghost is
contrary to received opinion
within the laws of nature that is not
supernatural
now in all that i had hitherto witnessed
and indeed in all the wonders which the
amateurs of mystery and our age record
as facts
a material living agency is always
required
on the continent you will find still
magicians who assert that they can raise
spirits
assume for the moment that they assert
truly still the living material form of
the magician is present
and he is the material agency by which
from some constitutional peculiarities
certain strange phenomena are
represented to your natural senses
except again as truthful the tales of
spirit manifestation in america
musical or other sounds writings on
paper produced by no discernible hand
articles of furniture moved without
apparent human agency
or the actual sight and touch of hands
to which no bodies seem to belong
still there must be found the medium or
living being
with constitutional peculiarities
capable of obtaining these signs
in fine in all such marvels supposing
even that there is no imposter
there must be a human being like
ourselves by whom or through whom
the effects presented to human beings
are produced
it is so with a now familiar phenomena
of mesmerism or electrobiology
the mind of the person operated on is
affected through a material living agent
nor supposing it true that a mesmerized
patient can respond to the will or
passes of a mesmerizer 100 miles distant
is the response less occasioned by a
material being
it may be through a material fluid call
it electric
call it odic call it what you will which
has the power of traversing
space and passing obstacles that the
material effect is communicated from one
to the other
hence all that i had hitherto witnessed
or expected to witness
in this strange house i believe to be
occasioned through some agency or medium
as mortal as myself
and this idea necessarily prevented the
awe with which those who regard as
supernatural things that are not within
the ordinary operations of nature
might have been impressed by the
adventures of that memorable night
as then it was my conjecture that all
that was presented
or would be presented to my senses must
originate in some human being
gifted by constitution with the power so
to present them
and having some motive so to do i felt
an interest in my theory
which in its way was rather
philosophical than superstitious
and i can sincerely say that i was in as
tranquil attempter for observation
as any practical experimentalist could
be in awaiting the effects of some rare
though perhaps perilous chemical
combination
of course the more i kept my mind
detached from fancy the more the temper
fitted for observation would be obtained
and i therefore riveted eye and thought
on the strong daylight sense and the
page of my macaulay
i now became aware that something
interposed between the page and the
light
the page was overshadowed i looked up
and i saw what i shall find it very
difficult perhaps
impossible to describe it was a darkness
shaping itself forth from the air and
very undefined outline
i cannot say it was of human form and
yet it had more resemblance to a human
form
or rather shadow than to anything else
as it stood wholly apart and distinct
from the air and the light around it
its dimensions seemed gigantic the
summit nearly touching the ceiling
while i gazed a feeling of intense cold
seized me
an iceberg before me could not have more
chilled me
nor could the cold of an iceberg have
been more purely physical
i feel convinced that it was not the
cold caused by fear
as i continued to gaze i thought but
this i cannot say with precision
that i distinguish two eyes looking down
on me from the height
one moment i fancied that i
distinguished them clearly
the next they seemed gone but still two
rays of a pale blue light frequently
shot through the darkness
as from the height on which i half
half-doubted
that i had encountered the eyes i strove
to speak
my voice utterly failed me i can only
think to myself
is this fear it is not fear i strove to
rise
in vain i felt as if weighted down by an
irresistible force
indeed my impression was that of an
immense and overwhelming power
opposed to my volition that sense of
utter inadequacy to cope with a force
beyond man's
which one may feel physically in a storm
at sea in a conflagration
or when confronting some terrible wild
beast or rather perhaps
the shark of the ocean i felt morally
opposed to my will was another will as
far superior to its strength as storm
fire and shark
are superior in material force to the
force of man
and now as this impression grew on me
now came at last
horror horror to a degree that no words
can convey
still i retained pride if not courage
and in my own mind i said
this is horror but it is not fear unless
i fear i cannot be harmed
my reason rejects this thing it is an
illusion
i do not fear with a violent effort i
succeeded at last in stretching out my
hand towards the weapon on the table
as i did so on the arm and shoulder i
received a strange
shock and my arm fell to my side
powerless
and now to add to my horror the light
began slowly to wane from the candles
they were not as it were extinguished
but their flame seemed very gradually
withdrawn
it was the same with the fire the light
was extracted from the fuel
in a few minutes the room was in utter
darkness
the dread that came over me to be thus
in the dark with that dark thing
whose power was so intensely felt
brought a reaction of nerve
in fact terror had reached that climax
that either my senses must have deserted
me
or i must have burst through the spell i
did burst through it
i found voice though the voice was a
shriek
i remember that i broke forth with words
like these
i do not fear my soul does not fear and
at the same time i found strength to
rise
still in that profound gloom i rushed to
one of the windows
tore aside the curtain flung open the
shutters my first thought was
light and when i saw the moon high clear
and calm
i felt a joy that almost compensated for
the previous terror
there was the moon there was also the
light from the gas lamps and the
deserted slumberous street
i turned to look back into the room the
moon penetrated its shadow very paley
and partially
but still there was light the dark thing
whatever it might be was gone except
that i could yet see a dim
shadow which seemed the shadow of that
shade against the opposite wall
my eye now rested on the table and from
under the table
which was without cloth or cover an old
mahogany round table
there rose a hand visible as far as the
wrist
it was a hand seemingly as much of flesh
and blood as my own
but the hand of an aged person lean
wrinkled
small too a woman's hand that hand very
softly closed on the two letters that
lay on the table
hand and letters both vanished there
then came the same three loud measured
knocks
i had heard at the bed head before this
extraordinary drama had commenced
as those sounds slowly ceased i felt the
whole room vibrate sensibly
and at the far end there rose as from
the floor
sparks or globules like bubbles of light
many colored
green yellow fire red azure
up and down to and fro hither thither as
tiny will of the wisps
the sparks moved slow or swift each had
its own caprice
a chair as in the drawing room below was
now advanced from the wall without a
parent agency
and placed at the opposite side of the
table
[Music]
suddenly as forth from the chair there
grew a shape
a woman's shape it was distinct as a
shape of life
ghastly as a shape of death the face was
that of youth
with a strange mournful beauty the
throat and shoulders were bare
the rest of the form in a loose robe of
cloudy white
it began sleeking its long yellow hair
which fell
over its shoulders its eyes were not
turned towards me but to the door
it seemed listening watching waiting
the shadow of the shade in the
background grew darker
and again i thought i beheld the eyes
gleaming out from the summit of the
shadow
eyes fixed upon that shape as if from
the door
though it did not open there grew out
another shape
equally distinct equally ghastly a man's
shape
a young man's it was in the dress of the
last century
or rather an alikeness of such dress for
both the male shape and the female
though defined were evidently
unsubstantial
impalpable simulacra phantasms
and there was something incongruous
grotesque
yet fearful in the contrast between the
elaborate finery
the courtly precision of that
old-fashioned garb with its ruffles and
lace and buckles
and the corpse-like aspect and
ghost-like stillness of the flitting
wearer
just as the male shape approached the
female the dark shadow started from the
wall
all three for a moment wrapped in
darkness
when the pale light returned the two
phantoms were as if in the grasp of the
shadow that towered between them
and there was a blood stain on the
breast of the female and the phantom
male was leaning on its phantom sword
and blood seemed trickling fast from the
ruffles from the lace
and the darkness of the intermediate
shadow swallowed them up
they were gone and again the bubbles of
light
shot and sailed and undulated growing
thicker and thicker
and more wildly confused in their
movements
the closet door to the right of the
fireplace now opened
and from the aperture there came the
form of an aged woman
in her hand she held letters the very
letters over which i had seen the hand
close
and behind her i heard a footstep she
turned round as if to listen
and then she opened the letters and
seemed to read and over her shoulder i
saw a livid face
the face as of a man long drowned
bloated
bleached seaweed tangled in its dripping
hair
and at her feet lay a form as of a
corpse and beside the corpse there
cowered a child
a miserable squalid child with famine in
its cheeks
and fear in its eyes and as i looked in
the old woman's face
the wrinkles and lines vanished and it
became a face of youth
hard-eyed stony but still youth and the
shadow darted forth
and darkened over these phantoms as it
had darkened over the last
nothing now was left but the shadow and
on that my eyes were intently fixed
till again eyes grew out of the shadow
malignant
serpent eyes and the bubbles of light
again
rose and fell and in their disordered
irregular
turbulent maze mingled with the wan
moonlight
and now from these globules themselves
as from the shell of an egg
monstrous things burst out the air grew
filled with them
larvae so bloodless and so hideous that
i can in no way describe them
except to remind the reader of the
swarming life which the solar microscope
brings before his eyes in a drop of
water
things transparent supple agile chasing
each other
devouring each other forms like not ever
be held by the naked eye
as the shapes were without symmetry so
their movements were without
order in their very vagrancies there was
no sport
they came round me and round thicker and
faster and swifter
swarming over my head crawling over my
right arm
which was outstretched in involuntary
command against all evil beings
sometimes i felt myself touched but not
by them
invisible hands touched me once i felt
the clutch as of cold soft fingers at my
throat
i was still equally conscious that if i
gave way to fear i should be in bodily
peril
and i concentrated all my faculties in
the single focus of resisting stubborn
will
and i turned my sight from the shadow
above all from those strange serpent
eyes
eyes that had now become distinctly
visible
for there though and not else around me
i was aware that there was a will
and a will of intense creative working
evil
which might crush down my own the pale
atmosphere in the room began now to
redden as if in the air of some near
conflagration
the larvae grew lurid as things that
live in fire
again the room vibrated again we heard
the three measured knocks
and again all things were swallowed up
in the darkness of the dark shadow
as if out of that darkness all had come
into that darkness
all returned as the gloom receded
the shadow was wholly gone slowly as it
had been withdrawn
the flame grew again into the candles on
the table
again into the fuel in the grate the
whole room came once more
calmly healthfully into sight the two
doors were still closed
the door communicating with the
servant's room still locked
in the corner of the wall into which he
had so convulsively niched himself
lay the dog i called to him no movement
i approached the animal was dead
his eyes protruded his tongue out of his
mouth
the froth gathered round his jaws i took
him in my arms
i brought him to the fire i felt acute
grief for the loss of my poor favorite
acute self-reproach i accused myself of
his death
i imagined he had died of fright but
what was my surprise on finding that his
neck was actually broken
had this been done in the dark must it
not have been by a hand human as
mine must there not have been a human
agency all the while in that room
good cause to suspect it i cannot tell
i cannot do more than state the fact
fairly the reader may draw his own
inference
another surprising circumstance my watch
was restored to the table
from which it had been so mysteriously
withdrawn but it had stopped at the very
moment it was so withdrawn
nor despite all the skill of the
watchmaker has it ever gone
since that is it will go in a strange
erratic way for a few hours and then
come to a dead stop
it is worthless nothing more chanced for
the rest of the night
nor indeed had i longed to wait before
the dawn broke
nor till it was broad daylight did i
quit the haunted house
before i did so i revisited the little
blind room in which my servant and
myself had been for a time imprisoned
i had a strong impression for which i
could not account
that from that room had originated the
mechanism of the phenomena
if i may use the term which had been
experienced in my chamber
and though i entered it now in the clear
day with the sun
peering through the filmy window i still
felt as i stood on its floors
the creep of the horror which i had
first there experienced the night before
and which had been so aggravated by what
had passed in my own chamber
i could not indeed bear to stay more
than a half a minute within those walls
i descended the stairs and again i heard
the footfall before me
and when i opened the street door i
thought i could distinguish a very low
laugh
i gained my own home expecting to find
my runaway servant there
but he had not presented himself nor did
i hear more of him for three days
when i received a letter from him dated
from liverpool
to this effect honored sir
i humbly entreat your pardon though i
can scarcely hope that you will think
that i deserve it
unless which heaven forbid you saw what
i did
i feel that it will be years before i
can recover myself
and as to being fit for service it is
out of the question
i am therefore going to my
brother-in-law at melbourne
the ship sails tomorrow perhaps the long
voyage may set me up
i do nothing now but start and tremble
and fancy it is behind me
i humbly beg you honored sir to order my
clothes
and whatever wages are due to me to be
sent to my mothers at walworth
john knows her address the letter ended
with additional apologies
somewhat incoherent and explanatory
details as to effects that had been
under the writer's charge
this flight may perhaps warrant a
suspicion that the man wished to go to
australia
and had been somehow or other
fraudulently mixed up with the events of
the night
i say nothing in refutation of that
conjecture
rather i suggest it as one that would
seem to many persons the most probable
solution
of improbable occurrences my belief in
my own theory
remained unshaken i returned in the
evening to the house
to bring away in a hat cab the things i
had left there with my poor dog's body
in this task i was not disturbed nor did
any incident worth note befall me
except that still on ascending and
descending the stairs
i heard the same footfall in advance on
leaving the house
i went to mr jays he was at home
i returned him the keys told him that my
curiosity was sufficiently gratified
and was about to relate quickly what had
passed when he stopped me
and said though with much politeness
that he had no longer any interest in a
mystery which none had ever solved
i determined at least to tell him of the
two letters i had read
as well as of the extraordinary manner
in which they had disappeared
and i then inquired if he thought they
had been addressed to the woman who had
died in the house
and if there were anything in her early
history which could possibly confirm the
dark suspicions to which the letters
gave
rise mr j seemed startled
and after musing a few moments answered
i am but little acquainted with the
woman's earlier history
except as i before told you that her
family were known to mine but you revive
some vague reminiscences to her
prejudice
i will make inquiries and inform you of
their result
still even if we could admit the popular
superstition that a person who had been
either the perpetrator or the victim of
dark crimes and life could revisit
as a restless spirit the scene in which
those crimes had been committed
i should observe that the house was
infested by strange sights and sounds
before the old woman died
you smile what would you say i would say
this
that i am convinced if we could get to
the bottom of these mysteries
we should find a living human agency
what you believe it is all an imposter
for what object
not an imposture in the ordinary sense
of the word if suddenly i were to sink
into a deep sleep
from which you could not awake me but in
that sleep could answer
questions with an accuracy which i could
not pretend to when awake
tell you what money you had in your
pocket may describe your very thoughts
it is not necessarily an imposter any
more than it is necessarily supernatural
i should be unconsciously to myself
under a mesmeric influence
conveyed to me from a distance by a
human being who had acquired power over
me by previous rapport
but if a mesmerizer could so affect
another living being
can you suppose that a mesmerizer could
also affect inanimate objects
move chairs open and shut doors or
impress our senses with the belief in
such effects
we never having been and rapport with
the person acting on us
no what is commonly called mesmerism
could not do this
but there may be a power akin to
mesmerism and superior to it the power
that in the old days was called magic
but such a power may extend to all
inanimate objects of matter
i do not say but if so it would not be
against nature
it would be only a rare power in nature
which might be given to constitutions
with certain peculiarities
and cultivated by practice to an
extraordinary degree
that such a power might extend over the
dead that is over certain thoughts and
memories that the dead may still retain
and compel not that which ought properly
to be called the soul
but which is far beyond human reach but
rather a phantom of what has been most
earth-stained on earth
to make itself apparent to our senses is
a very ancient though obsolete theory
upon which i will hazard no opinion but
i do not conceive the power would be
supernatural
let me illustrate what i mean from an
experiment which paracelsus described as
not difficult
and which the author of the curiosities
of literature cites is credible
a flower perishes you burn it whatever
were the elements of that flower while
it lived
are gone dispersed you know not wither
you can never discover nor recollect
them but you can by
chemistry out of the burned dust of that
flower raise a spectrum of the flower
just as it seemed in life it may be the
same with a human being
the soul has as much escaped you as the
essence or elements of the flower
still you may make a spectrum of it and
this phantom
though in the popular superstition it is
held to be the soul of the departed
must not be confounded with the true
soul it is but the eidolon of the dead
form
hence like the best attested stories of
ghosts or spirits
the thing that most strikes us is the
absence of what we hold to be
soul that is of superior emancipated
intelligence
these apparitions come for little or no
object they seldom speak when they do
come
if they speak they utter no ideas above
those of an ordinary person on earth
american spirit seers have published
volumes of communications
in prose and verse which they assert to
be given in the names of the most
illustrious dead shakespeare bacon
heaven knows whom
those communications taking the best are
certainly not a wit of higher order than
would be communications from living
persons of fair talent and education
they are wondrously inferior to what
bacon shakespeare and plato
said and wrote when on earth nor what is
more noticeable
did they ever contain an idea that was
not on the earth before
wonderful therefore as such phenomena
may be granting them to be truthful
i see much that philosophy may question
nothing that it is incumbent on
philosophy to deny
namely nothing supernatural they are but
ideas conveyed somehow or other
we have not yet discovered the means
from one mortal brain to another
whether in so doing tables walk of their
own accord
or fiend-like shapes appear in a magic
circle our bodyless hands rise and
remove material objects
or a thing of darkness such as presented
itself to me
frees our blood still am i persuaded
that these are but agencies conveyed as
by electric wires
to my own brain from the brain of
another
in some constitutions there is a natural
chemistry
and those constitutions may produce
chemic wonders
in others a natural fluid call it
electricity
and these may produce electric wonders
but the wonders differ from normal
science in this
they are alike objectless purposeless
puri
frivolous they lead on to no grand
results
and therefore the world does not heed
and true sages have not cultivated them
but sure i am that of all i saw or heard
a man human as myself was the remote
originator
and i believe unconsciously to himself
as to the exact effects produced
for this reason no two persons you say
have ever told you that they experienced
exactly the same thing
we'll observe no two persons ever
experience exactly the same dream
if this were an ordinary imposture the
machinery would be arranged for results
that would but little vary
if it were a supernatural agency
permitted by the almighty
it would surely be for some definite end
these phenomena belong to neither class
my persuasion is that they originate in
some brain now far
distant that that brain had no distinct
volition in anything that occurred
that what does occur reflects but its
devious motley ever-shifting half-formed
thoughts
in short that it has been but the dreams
of such a brain
put into action and invested with a
semi-substance
that this brain is of immense power that
it can set matter into movement
that it is malignant and destructive i
believe some material force must have
killed my dog
the same force might fraud i know have
sufficed to kill myself
had i been as subjugated by terror as
the dog had my intellect or my spirit
given me no countervailing resistance in
my will
it killed your dog that is fearful
indeed it is strange that no animal can
be induced to stay in that house
not even a cat bats and mice are never
found in it
the instincts of the brute creation
detect influences deadly to their
existence
man's reason has a sense less subtle
because it has a resisting power
more supreme but enough do you
comprehend my theory
yes though imperfectly and i accept any
crotchet
pardon the word however odd rather than
embrace at once the notion of ghosts and
hobgoblins we imbibed in our nurseries
still to my unfortunate house the evil
is the same
what on earth can i do with the house
i will tell you what i would do i am
convinced from my own internal feelings
that the small
unfurnished room at right angles to the
door of the bedroom which i occupied
forms a starting point or receptacle for
the influences which haunt the house
and i strongly advise you to have the
walls opened the floor removed
nay the whole room pulled down i
observed that it is detached from the
body of the house
built over the small backyard and could
be removed without injury to the rest of
the building
and you think if i did that you would
cut off the telegraph wires
try it i'm so persuaded that i am right
that i will pay half the expense if you
will allow me to direct the operations
nay i am well able to afford the cost
for the rest allow me to write to you
about 10 days after i received a letter
from mr j
telling me that he had visited the house
since i had seen him that he had found
the two letters i had described
replaced in the drawer from which i had
taken them that he had read them with
misgivings like my own
that he had instituted a cautious
inquiry about the woman to whom i
rightly conjectured they had been
written
it seemed that 36 years ago a year
before the date of the letters
she had married against the wish of her
relations an american
a very suspicious character in fact he
was generally believed to have been a
pirate
she herself was the daughter of very
respectable tradespeople
and had served in the capacity of a
nursery governess before her marriage
she had a brother a widower who was
considered wealthy
and who had one child of about six years
old
a month after the marriage the body of
this brother was found in the thames
near london bridge there seemed some
marks of violence about his throat
but they were not deemed sufficient to
warrant the inquest in any other verdict
than that of found drowned
the american and his wife took charge of
the little boy
the deceased brother having by his will
left his sister the guardian of his only
child
in an event of the child's death the
sister inherited
the child died about six months
afterwards it was supposed to have been
neglected and ill-treated
the neighbors deposed to have heard it
shriek at night
the surgeon who had examined it after
death said that it was emaciated as if
from want of nourishment
and the body was covered with livid
bruises
it seemed that one winter night the
child had sought to escape
crept out into the backyard tried to
scale the wall
fallen back exhausted and been found at
mourning on the stones in a dying state
but though there was some evidence of
cruelty there was none of murder
and the aunt and her husband had sought
to palliate cruelty by alleging the
exceeding stubbornness and perversity of
the child
who was declared to be half-witted be
that as it may
at the orphan's death the ant inherited
her brother's fortune
before the first wedded year was out the
american quitted england abruptly
and never returned to it he obtained a
cruising vessel which was lost in the
atlantic
two years afterwards the widow was left
in affluence
but reverses of various kinds had
befallen her
a bank broke an investment failed she
went into a small business and became
insolvent
then she entered into service sinking
lower and lower
from housekeeper down to maid of all
work never long retaining a place
though nothing decided against her
character was ever alleged
she was considered sober honest and
peculiarly quiet in her ways
still nothing prospered with her and so
she had dropped into the workhouse
from which mr j had taken her to be
placed in charge of the very house which
she had rented as mistress
in the first year of her wedded life mr
j
added that he had passed an hour alone
in the unfurnished room which i had
urged him to
destroy and that his impressions of
dread while there were so great
though he had neither heard nor seen
anything that he was eager to have the
walls bared and the floors removed as i
had suggested
he had engaged persons for the work and
would commence any day i would name
the day was accordingly fixed i repaired
to the haunted house
we went into the blind dreary room took
up the skirting
and then the floors under the rafters
covered with rubbish
was found a trapdoor quite large enough
to admit a man
it was closely nailed down with clamps
and rivets of iron
on removing these we descended into a
room below
the existence of which had never been
suspected
in this room there had been a window and
a flu but they had been bricked over
evidently for many years by the help of
candles we examined this place
it still retained some molding furniture
three chairs an oak settle
a table all of the fashion of about 80
years ago
there was a chest of drawers against the
wall in which we found
half rotted away old-fashioned articles
of a man's dress
such as might have been worn 80 or 100
years ago by a gentleman of some rank
costly steel buckles and buttons like
those yet worn in court dresses
a handsome court sword in a waistcoat
which had once been rich with gold lace
but which was now blackened and foul
with damp we found
five guineas a few silver coins and an
ivory ticket
probably for some place of entertainment
long since passed away
but our main discovery was in a kind of
iron safe
fixed to the wall the lock of which it
cost us much trouble to get picked
in this safe were three shelves and two
small drawers
ranged on the shelves were several small
bottles of crystal
hermetically stopped they contained
colorless volatile essences
of the nature of which i shall only say
that they were not poisons
phosphor and ammonia entered into some
of them
there were also some very curious glass
tubes and a small pointed rod of iron
with a large lump of rock crystal and
another of amber
also a lodestone of great power in one
of the drawers we found a miniature
portrait set in gold
and retaining the freshness of its
colors most remarkably
considering the length of time it had
probably been there
the portrait was that of a man who might
be somewhat advanced in middle life
perhaps 47 or 48. it was a remarkable
face
a most impressive face if you could
fancy some mighty serpent transformed
into man
preserving in the human lineaments the
old serpent type
you would have a better idea of that
countenance than long descriptions can
convey
the width and flatness of frontal the
tapering elegance of contour disguising
the strength of the deadly jaw
the long large terrible eye glittering
and green as the emerald
and with all a certain ruthless calm as
if from the consciousness of an immense
power
mechanically i turned round the
miniature to examine the back of it
and on the back was engraved a pentacle
in the middle of the pentacle
a ladder and the third step of the
ladder was formed by the date
1765. examining still more minutely i
detected a spring
this on being pressed opened the back of
the miniature as a lid
with inside the lid were engraved
marianna to thee
be faithful in life and in death too
here follows a name that i will not
mention but it was not unfamiliar to me
i had heard it spoken of by old men in
my childhood
as the same born by a dazzling charlatan
who had made a great sensation in london
for a year or so and had fled the
country on the charge of a double murder
within his own house
that of his mistress and his rival i
said nothing of this to mr j
to whom i reluctantly resigned the
miniature
we had found no difficulty in opening
the first drawer within the iron safe
we found great difficulty in opening the
second it was not locked
but it resisted all efforts till we
inserted in the chinks the edge of a
chisel
when we had thus drawn it forth we found
a very singular apparatus in the nicest
order
upon a small thin book or rather tablet
was placed a saucer of crystal
this saucer was filled with a clear
liquid on that liquid floated a kind of
compass
with a needle shifting rapidly round but
instead of the usual points of a compass
were seven strange characters not very
unlike those used by astrologers to
denote the planets
a peculiar but not strong nor
displeasing odor came from this drawer
which was lined with a wood that we
afterwards discovered to be hazel
whatever the cause of this odor it
produced a material effect on the nerves
we all felt it even the two workmen who
were in the room
a creeping tingling sensation from the
tips of the fingers to the roots of the
hair
impatient to examine the tablet i
removed the saucer
as i did so the needle of the compass
went round and round
with exceeding swiftness and i felt a
shock that ran through my whole frame
so that i dropped the saucer on the
floor the liquid was spilled
the saucer was broken the compass rolled
to the end of the room
and at that instant the walls shook to
and fro as if a giant had swayed and
rocked them
the two workmen were so frightened that
they ran up the ladder by which we had
descended from the trapdoor
but seeing that nothing more happened
they were easily induced to return
meanwhile i had opened the tablet it was
bound in plain red leather
with a silver clasp it contained but one
sheet of thick vellum
and on that sheet were inscribed within
a double pentacle
words in old monkish latin which are
literally to be translated thus
on all that it can reach within these
walls sentient or inanimate
living or dead as moves the needle so
work my will
a cursed be the house and restless be
the dwellers therein
we found no more mr j burned the tablet
and its anathema he raised to the
foundations the part of the building
containing the secret room with the
chamber over it
he had then the courage to inhabit the
house himself for a month
and a quieter better conditioned house
could not be found in all london
subsequently he led it to advantage and
his tenant
has made no complaints
you